il est un peu moins de 7 heures ce
dimanche là timoko chez un ami viennent
de sortir de boîtes de nuit quand ils
sont pris à partie par un groupe
d'individus
l'altercation a lieu rue jeanne-d'arc et
elle tourne très vite au drame
tibou reçoit un coup de poignard fatal
qui lui sectionne la carotide transporté
à l'hôpital dans un état d'urgence
absolue
le jeune homme décède quelques heures
plus tard le drame bouleverse la cité
ducale mais aussi varennes vauzelles où
habitait thibault et le cfa de mardi où
il était apprenti joyeux lurons un
coluche numéro dessus on peut dire comme
ça un petit peu de temps en temps
toujours une blague toujours toujours de
bonne humeur du gamin deux jours après
les faits le meurtrier présumé de
thibaut âgé d'à peine 20 ans vient se
rendre au commissariat de nevers
accompagné de son père et de son avocat
et la faire connaître un double
rebondissement en octobre un deuxième
suspect est interpellé et mis en examen
poursuivi pour avoir frappé l'ami de la
victime et en novembre deux autres
hommes sont mises en cause pour
non-assistance à personne en danger et
violences en réunion
le procès de ses quatre agresseurs
présumés devrait permettre d'éclaircir
le contexte et le mobile de ce drame